any peens
three peens in a pod is that what
they're talking about hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome back to
pogo stuck there was a whole new map
made
an entire new map i didn't even beat the
first map mostly because i didn't want
to and it's not that i want to do the
second map but it's like i feel that
character on the right makes me itchy
the one that's all dots i don't like
that
i didn't finish the first map and i
don't necessarily want to do this
because
i don't think i'm going to enjoy the
experience but i like a challenge
i like a challenge i do
i do like a challenge so i'm going to
try it
oh the last thing i want is other people
in here god
get me out of here i don't want anyone
else possibly
i just don't even get near me don't look
at me knuckles how do i turn off
everything
is there a way to turn off everything is
their way to not do this with people
how do i not do this with anybody i
don't want to do with anybody
okay sure i forget how to make it not
anybody be
well interesting welcome to matt 2.
you have a 1 000 meter vertical climb
ahead of you while the difficulty may be
off the charts i encourage you to try
and get as far as you can
the bigger the risk the bigger the
payoff will be when you finally pull it
off
you can play on your own or with friends
or strangers in the rubber band co-op
mode in the if the difficulty is too
much
you can try a more accessible double
jump or 720 boost modes
no i would never do such a thing thank
you for playing my game believe in
yourself and remember
perseverance is key super cool developer
i don't know what i'm doing here why am
i here why have i done this to myself
oh that's a hill i thought it was the
background oh no
oh why wasn't that a super boost no oh
my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god
nope i'm fine no i'm not fine so it's
been a while since i played this game i
generally remember the
the pretty much basic ways of the way it
goes
oh god here we go oh no
i remember the basic ways of playing the
kind of like the angular momentum and
yadda yadda if i say angler angler
momentum that makes me sound smart
maybe i'm more zen than i've been in the
past why is it doing that stupid music i
don't like that music
can it not do that music is there a
setting to not have that music play
every time
i really wish there was uh
well i'm able to get there consistently
can the music stop thank you
i don't want any of that i don't need
any of that
let's turn the other players down too i
don't see a way to do it solo so i guess
i'm just gonna have to keep up with
everybody here
so i'm pretty good at the game in case
you guys didn't know i know may
i know my way around a pogo so if anyone
thinks that i'm not gonna be able to
perform it oh god
there we go yes yes yes
yes easy peasy so
what is the goo is the goo good
i'm gonna guess the goo's good i can't
touch the goo that's not a that's a cat
purring and that's clearly an
um armadillo okay is this goo good nope
it's the bad gu
okay i should have known okay so it's a
bouncy pad basically
oh boy i have no idea how that's
possible
no that's not how
yes yes no i'm fine
cuz i'm fine that's all i do no
i'm fine cause i'm fine
that's how i do and this is nope that's
the wrong but that's
the right one
okay so i just gotta get through this
maggot
i think it's a maggot it looks like a
maggot i'm fine
i'm so good look at how good i am
oh boy no wait no i'm fine
i'm gonna be okay okay i'm gonna be fine
i keep can i not do straight up and down
that'd be
so good if i could not no
no well that was uh unfortunate the per
the the purpose the purpose the purpose
blurpus
is perseverance it's persevering in the
face of adversity
okay so i don't need a boost for this i
know
ah titty sprinkles that's you know
there's also a nuance that i
i never really picked up in the in the
last time i played this which was the
nuance of
not always holding down the shooty
button
it's just uh you know it's it's a it's
an unfortunate
side effect of my need to hold the sh
what was i trying to accomplish i
am never going to make it back up no
this is a fool's errand
i've made it back up no a fool
oh a fool why do i always have to
holding down the shooty button
it's like how i learned to play oh what
was that
what did i do what even was that
possible thing that it did to me
don't think that you're gonna
[Music]
i am hippity-hoppity all the way
i'm fine i'm not fine the main problem
with this is joy
is just my inability to be consistent
when i'm frazzled and when i get
frazzled
things like hitting the ceiling and then
pogoing
like that i don't know what that would
no i
knew that i couldn't do that hey
stop stop start
start oh yeah baby yeah baby that's what
i'm
talking about i'm flipping for no reason
okay not hold it down all the time maybe
what if it's what if it's enough what if
you know
[Music]
no that'll never work maybe it will
my chance to be the very best
oh crap i'm up
i'm not up i'm so
un-up here we go watch this amazingness
watch this amazingness my amazingness
has come back i can feel it flowing
through my veins and my butt no i'm fine
see this part isn't that hard even
though it seems like it's that hard
based on my screaming but it
really i don't think do you need oh yeah
you do oh my god
oh my god oh my god
oh my god yeah
i hate everything i hate i hate all of
it i hate all of this
and this where'd you come from exploding
out of the dark
look you think you're fancy-footed watch
my fancy
what's with the bees who knocked down
bees
where were bees they're bees in this
game
10 out of 10. i love the bees
oh well nailed it
no i didn't no okay hey
buddy yes yes
yes so i think you do need an explodey
to be able to get up there
to be able to get up there oh crap
that's what i
really don't want to do okay so it's
it's about you know you really gotta you
really gotta fine tune it sometimes
oh my god i'm doomed this is how i get
doomed this is how doom comes to me
i'm doomed but that they all that was
progress it wasn't really progress
because i didn't get any farther but
in my heart i feel like there was
problem
gross yes i'm so good at this game
i am so unbelievably good and big bald
try this again all right why
the b oh that's your stupid ability i
thought that was cool
i hate that and i hate you and i hate
myself
most of all but shut up about me this is
about you
why did b-man have to get over here why
does anybody customize anything
customizing is for babies i'm a real man
default skin for life
okay so i just need to find the right
amount and oh that was that was pretty
good though okay they're
they're starting from over here let me
watch what knuckles does okay
knuckles is screwing it up knuckles is a
big loser knuckles is big dumb
me big smart big brain
oh knuckles didn't do it but they're
doing it from up here so it is kind of a
oh no i'm going back baby here i come
i'm coming back nailed it
look guys we all knew what we were
getting into there's a whole lot of me
being egotistical about abilities that i
don't actually have
and a whole lot of these guys making me
look bad
yes i am the best oh
no got it nailed it i'm the best
officially reclaimed title of the last
ever best ever best ever no one's ever
been better
no one ever could be better oh my god
i'm so good
literally no one's ever been nearly as
goodly as i ever
have been in my life i'm so goddamn
amazing at this game
jesus christmas look at me go yes
yes no fine
there's definitely something to be said
about trying to do
a complex physical task while talking
talking takes up a big portion of the
brain and as big as my brain is
hi how you doing as big as my brain is
i'm i'm only so much of a genius
you know i would never claim to be the
biggest genius in the world
i i just uh you know i'm my genius is
huge and all
we all know this but if i were to oh
okay
hey buddy if i were to have to quantify
anything
it would be the oh oh my god please i
want to live
yes among the stars i'm gonna make this
oh my god i made it oh my god i made it
oh my god i made it
where am i going where am i going after
this which way do i flip
i'm gonna flip you now i'm making it
back up
yes i'm the greatest that ever
lived and oh my god i almost screwed
that up
you know what i didn't because i didn't
need full power and i
subconsciously knew that i'm gonna make
this
back up here oh no
i didn't make it nope can i please go
right there we go
what was that is that one of the
accessibility modes
they didn't tell me accessibility gave
you superpowers
anyway i'm mad this [ __ ] let's see
this laser crap you know that's that's
really what ruins
oh ruins the experience for everyone
trying to actually be
cool just on their own you think you can
supplement your coolness with effects
and you cannot
there we go perfect easy easy i know how
this works
okay nope that's not good go back go
back no
please i just wanna not
be no my god where's this taking me
i don't understand the physics of this
game sometimes i mean at least it's
consistent
kind of kind of anyway guys listen
listen listen guys you're not listening
to me when you need to listen you need
to listen
you're not listening you're not
listening at home i i can i can hear you
typing
if you just get good man it wouldn't be
that bad
oh my god i'm up
like a bird oh here i am apparently
he nailed it i'm the best ever in the
history of forever
i'm the best i'm the best yes
no yes no
no no
oh god no why would you stick to the
ceiling
when i'm clearly trying to thump it with
my rump all i'm trying to do is thump it
with my rump so that it bounce off
harmlessly and then i can recreate my
pogo
that i previously did no go on and then
i'd be able to go
go on my pogo see why would you stick to
the ceiling why
you know it's probably my fault but i'm
not willing to take the blame
i made it oh you wouldn't stick then
really you wouldn't stick then
oh gosh
yes easy nailed it nailed it nailed this
nail oh my god yes please
i'm the greatest oh no i'm not the
greatest
i'm the greatest yes
this is how winning is done baby
this is how winning is done okay this is
how
winning is done winning no
yes still possible yes
more than possible doing oh not doing
not
possible more than possible yes
yes no yes okay calmly down
and whoa yes that's how you do it that's
how you don't hold down on the bang
button and then
oh no okay i'm going to go off of this
wall here
yes easy oh my god no oh my god oh my
god
life flashed before my eyes what is this
oh oh what what is that no what no
hey wait a minute hey wait a minute
that's not cool what were you doing
there what are you thinking you were
doing
because it wasn't cool whatever it was i
hate everything
i don't know what all that was all about
because that that seems like it might be
crap
i have a limited tolerance for crap
and it seems as though may oh okay
no no what no my goodness get me off
this maggot
no why was that not a super why was that
not a
super why would that not evolve
why would that not have been a super
jump
that was such a complete 360.
which is the only oh my god why would
you stick to that do you hate me
is that what you do game is that is that
what you are
you you're you're you you hate me oh my
god
after everything i've done for you oh my
god
that's entirely my fault you heard it
everybody it was entirely my fault
i am the only one to be blamed oh my god
i hate you
your stupid rockets why would they even
put that in the game that's
the worst thing oh my god i looked away
for one second and i almost
rocketed myself off back into the
beginning because my
nose is i'm very red in the face oh
cause my light isn't even pointed at me
i'm not even illuminated properly
that's better ain't it guys that's the
good lear
oh my god this is not okay this is what
you called not okay oh my god
not okay okay officially okay
boingus okay sprongus
yes i will not accept whatever the hell
that
what what did that just do what just
happened to me
why didn't what i don't like you guys i
don't like any of you
i don't like any of you oh my god oh my
god good thing i've got style and
pizzazz
yes who's that no what is that about
the achievement distracted me i didn't
know what the blue blue blub was about
and i hate it and i
oh god i just want to make it back up to
the upper
place where oh okay
then great
good freaking great
that's not a cat i refuse to believe
that's a cat
yes perfect as i always am
okay and then just like that no
can i oh no god damn it that's
tough it's really tough guys it actually
you know
it's kind of tough oh no i'm going to be
following this guy and i'm going to get
confused this is where i
am they are and all that crap
oh my god every time you cannot oh
explain wait lexie and go back on that
angle that i was on that wall there and
explain that one to me
explain that angle to me that was 89
degrees upside down against the wall
it's like you're stickier upside down
than you are right side up
no i just i fundamentally disagree with
whatever that was
i fundamentally disagree with that i
don't understand you'll you'll
you'll grab at impossible angles
and then the slightest off of normal and
it's like oh okay
it's so slippery up here on this
mountain it's just too slippery
okay that's kind i kind of wanted to let
go there but i didn't really want it to
do that when i let go so that's really
[ __ ] i'll be filing a complaint with
the pogo stuck department
and you are going to get your ass handed
to you handed to you
no that ain't right that's what you call
not right
nope that's also what you call why was i
charged there
i hit the ceiling why would i have been
charged
oh my god please don't
leave me like this
oh my god
no stupid
dumb stupid
dumb dumb and stupid
so we're up here now same old place here
i love it
oh no i didn't charge on ah
crap oh no just by an inch
my headphones came off that's always a
good sign i can't put him back on yet
though cause i could still
get back there's still a chance no the
gaming's too intense right now i don't
care if i'm back at the beginning no no
no there's still a chance
nah i couldn't possibly take a second to
put my headphones back on of which it's
very
uncomfortable i have i have a chance i
could stick the landing still it's just
a matter
there we go oh my god not like this oh
my god oh my god
why is it not flippity-flooping when i'm
jumping off of the maggot no why was
that not a
boost what what i thought i knew this
game
i really did i really thought i knew it
no oh i thought that was gonna happen
again
oh that should have been a boost here we
go
this is it is it is it is it yes
yes okay here we go yes
yes oh my goodness
oh my goodness oh my goodness okay all
right
okay
nope oh my god please yes i'm the best
that ever existed in the history of
forever i know this
i love this about myself okay
oh my god stop so there's something
going on here
i don't know what this is i don't know
how
you deal with that that's doesn't make
any sense
what are you supposed to do here okay it
doesn't make sense either way i'm gonna
end this here because i made some
progress
i'm gonna pick it back up but i can't
promise that i'll be any sort of sane
after this for every video that i make
of this i lose a little bit
of my life and i'll never get it back
but in exchange for that you have to
like this video you have to you are
obligated to if you don't
then all of the life that i'm losing is
for naught
if you haven't subscribed to see more
then you're just watching me waste away
and why would you do that
[Music]
how could you do that to me and not
subscribe
and not ring the bell yeah well i don't
even understand i try to make good
content
i just try thank you everybody so much
for watching
and as always i will see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
you